the Joe Rogan experience I always wanted
I mean I try to ask this to as many
musicians as possible but how do you
guys create music do you do write stuff
out and then come to the band - some of
the guys bring their own ideas for a
beat or for a concept or well you know I
like the randomness of it all and and
again I love collaboration I've never
done anything just me all by myself
that doesn't there are times when I make
you make a request of people who play
with me like I hear all of this can we
just try that first because and I like
to do that when someone says that in
return if they if they're like sometimes
you hear everything all at once and
that's how that is a gift and you kind
of don't want to mess with that you want
at least start from that point because
if someone does have an idea at least
they're starting from understanding
where this how this is and their saw
their idea if they have one is rooted in
this instead of being kind of arbitrary
you know does that make sense
mm-hmm and then so but it's great to
hear that and also be asked to kind of
be a soldier sometimes sure I'll play
because I'd love to hear that
all these puzzle pieces together right
right but I also respect their their
idea their vision whatever it is you're
just trying to help them realize it yeah
sometimes sometimes it's like that and
sometimes I'm requesting that and
there's a way to communicate that that
sounds exciting
yeah and you should because it's a shame
to be misunderstood in that moment when
really what you're saying is oh my god I
have this idea can we try just like this
for a start and once you're emerged in
this understanding your ideas to better
it will be based in understanding this
you guys are very unique and that you
don't sound like anybody else
but that's the point it is the point
that that in fact in fact I always
looked at that like do all that's the
minimum obligation right as to none it's
to not you know not sound like other
folks yeah the men without hats - you
know what's the point
you already hands everyone - I love that
song yeah it's great because it's sort
of a challenge yeah you can leave your
friends behind yeah
like what the [ __ ] what why would it if
they don't dancing no friends yeah like
sort of like drawing a dance line in the
sand you know it's a great song yes but
I but also there's there's that those
are the kind of two ends of the spectrum
right mm-hmm hearing hearing someone's
honestly and do an explaining yours
honestly and asking for help too
to do that well your your stuff is not
just unique it's unique in itself like
your songs are different each song is
different than the other songs is like
you don't there's not like a Queens the
Stone Age sound well I think there's a
band called weand that I love so much
and early on my first band Caius that
was trying to sound like itself itself
but singularly mm-hmm and I was feeling
painted in a corner a little bit by the
fact that it had to be in this mode and
we toured with this band ween because
who would play anything do you you know
who they aren't sure yeah yeah they're
so brilliant and they play a mister
would you please help my pony and we
were like what the [ __ ] is that about
and then they'd play riders on the storm
for 28 minutes when it was [ __ ]
incredible they never soundcheck it
you're like you just know and and what
they were was free mmm they said and
then they did a country record with all
these professional hired gun country you
know and it sounded incredible because
they were like because we can do that
why can't we yeah that manifesting what
you love period and so I just from being
around them and seeing things like that
and then starting this desert sessions
project which is what I just put out
recently where it's just collaboration
and it could be anything because it's
not all you you know but yet it's you
and so it was that's how Queens started
was like what if you just played
anything you thought was good no matter
what it was and you let every song I had
a friend of mine once say to me you know
not every song can be your best and I
and I just looked at him and it was like
why why what is that why is that I don't
even know why that has to be a
possibility why not
yeah what if you if you see through to
those spinning locks through to
the other side and a song could go there
you should take it there right I mean
that's what we're supposed to do yeah
and it's a weird pessimistic attitude
isn't it like not every song can be your
best and it was like oh I see you're
talking about are you talking about
here's talk about yours yeah I see you
mr. Howe went before the internet like
there was a lot of bands it would put
out like a few hits on an album but then
the rest the album would almost feel
like filler III again that's another
thing right it seemed to me at one point
in the my hope was that okay in the
spirit of trying to do something
different I call it on supply on demand
you know it's out there cuz it's out
there mm-hmm
what's not out there that would be
interesting to hear it tell me what what
you don't think we need and let's start
there right for for just trying to fill
in the gaps and beautifully fill in the
gaps of what's not represented and and
thereby having this limitless ability to
play whatever you thought was right in
the moment as long as it was honest then
you'd be fine you know and uh and so
that's always been I just I feel like it
would be fun to try that and so that's
why it's so jumps around stylistically
but I do think people listen to whatever
they think is good and they don't care
about genre what unless you're a
teenager when that's important to you or
that certainly was to me um why is John
Rowe important that seems like if you
work at a record store it's important
because you're filing these under like
you know nose flute in the key of yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] about genre I give a
[ __ ] about good I mean I listen to car
you have a taste of a metal yeah
something runs over it with its truck
tire you go hey [ __ ] I'm good yeah I'd
love to lick that again but I just it's
you know I like a song where you can
tell the band made something that they
like yeah you know I mean well this this
is another thing early on when we left
the desert and my first band Caius and
we were so proud like we we knew we
sounded different we thought this is
cool and so you make records you love
and you listen to them all the time
because because it's like you're
supposed to make your favorite music I
mean I was 15 years old what else was I
supposed to make I can't wait to make
the music I hate the most
it doesn't make sense right I just want
to do wedding so you meet you tour with
these bands you're like do you guys
listen your records cuz we would be in
the car on tour listen to our records
and then play our records and and they'd
be like [ __ ] hate that thing
and I'd be like no I said do you listen
to your own music like I couldn't
understand right what's wrong with
playing your favorite thing you always
wanted to play but it's not out there so
you create it that's all right it seems
like that's the job actually yeah
and how can you look how can you love my
stuff if I don't right right what what
are the [ __ ] chances like 0.0 us well
BIA is such a prison imagine if you
created a genre that was super popular
and people really loved it but you
[ __ ] hated it I did my first band
there's this really wonderful thing
happened the fans took over and they
owned it because we stopped and so they
took it over the fans kept it alive and
some people gave it a name stoner rock
what to me stoner rock was like Ozzy
when I was a kid like nausea baseball
shirts and sure I wanted to be a punk
rocker and it's like don't stoners over
there you know and so stoner rock I was
like no no and plus I don't want to wear
that I can appreciate anything that I
like so we don't need to call it
anything mm-hmm
because I'll just like whatever I like
no you could call it jazz rabbit that's
the style of music gonna be like [ __ ]
fantastic but I just like what I like in
that anyways yeah it's just a noise
you're making to do with your face yeah
Charlie Brown's teacher yeah I love that
style actually it's like exactly who
care right like I like what I like and
um and you know you get it flak for that
stuff for not like no sit here wear this
and I understand too because it's good
to feel part of something
[Applause]